my son who's 12 he and his friends got
into binge watching the office recently
and so he went through this whole
emotional journey and I walk in and out
at different times you know as he was
watching over the last couple of months
just binge watching and he'd be laughing
and then crying and so yeah when I tell
him that you were on the show he has
this whole connection with you that's
very special and a little creepy are you
noticing younger fans now yes yes
exactly what you're saying like the sort
of like 12 13 year olds up to like high
school yes I think because of Netflix
yes they've been binge watching and but
it's funny because they they come up to
me the high schoolers and stuff but they
they always say like you'll see me in
Target or something and they'll say
they'll say you know what excuse me I'm
so sorry but um does anyone ever tell
you you look like an older version of
that girl from the office now you look
the same you look fantastic like we you
know we did make the show a while ago
right I'm human person and I continued
they don't even believe me yeah I'll be
like yeah that's me and they're like no
but you do look like her yeah I do get
that I get people saying you look like
Conan O'Brien only you're much taller
than that guy I do get that all the time
they were like you're like does anyone
ever tell you except of course you're
much taller than that little creep
nothing like
he is a creep
you